[Música]
aunque eso es raro yo siento que la vida
es muy parecida a una construcción
antisísmica seguramente la mayoría de
ustedes no tengan ni la menor idea de lo
que estoy hablando bueno les cuento se
trata de una construcción que está
ubicada en las zonas donde normalmente
se producen muchos sismos y funciona de
tal manera y cuando hay algún momento
químico en vez de quedarse para en su
estructura normal se mueve al igual el
terremoto y esta manera no pierde
estabilidad
porque comparó esta estructura con la
vida bueno porque al igual que este
edificio uno en la vida tiene que ser
flexible para atravesar sus diferentes
terremotos o moviendo sísmicos cuáles
serían estos terremotos o en dos únicos
para ustedes
piensen porque para mí serían todos los
momentos inesperados que tuve que pasar
por ejemplo la separación de mis padres
moverme de casa cambiarme de colegio que
muchos mejores amigos se cambien de
colegio entrar a la secundaria y
adaptarme a ella
cuáles son las etapas de la vida ustedes
reconocen y recuerdan tenemos común
sería que no reconozca la infancia la
adolescencia y la adultez y la vejez
yo tengo 12 años se podría decir que
esté entrando en la adolescencia ahora
solo es una pregunta que sería atravesar
la adolescencia de una manera de una
buena manera tener muchos amigos aparte
muchos dieces la verdad es que todos
atravesamos esta etapa pero cada persona
lo hace de una manera diferente a la
otra
me pasó a ver el jardín fue básicamente
hacer nada más nada no pero creo que
todos hacíamos las típicas cosas niños
pequeños o sea tomamos una siesta no
sólo hemos pintado hemos dibujado un
salió de nuevo león sorbier otra siesta
supongo que esta habrá sido de las
mejores etapas para todos no oyó que
pueda mentira pero lo que hoy es creemos
muy chiquitos y docentes y aún no nos
damos cuenta las cosas que suceden a
nuestro alrededor
luego pasamos a la primaria aunque no
parezca para muchos de ustedes este fue
un cambio muy grande repito aunque no lo
parezca
creo que yo fue una persona con bastante
buena suerte porque el segundo grado de
primaria yo me mudé y me cambia de
colegio al mudarme no tuve absolutamente
ningún problema y lo mejor es que al
cambiarme del colegio tampoco estoy
estar cerrado en este colegio y aún así
conozco a mis compañeros como la palma
de mi mano son personas son personas con
las que compartir eventos divertidos y
aburridos felices y tristes en pelear y
merry les pasa una gran parte de lo poco
que por ahora vivir con ellos son
personas que sé que me van a acompañar
en todas las decisiones que tome a lo
largo de vida son parte de mi familia y
siempre van a hacer
estoy segura que todo estudio sería el
que estábamos rebajó ni a dos o teníamos
una bronca que se notaba de marte y
quienes fueron esas personas que nos
sacaron una sonrisa en estos momentos
los amigos le quise dedicar toda esta
parte de ellos porque siento que a lo
largo de la primaria uno atraviesa por
momentos inolvidables buenos y malos y
esos son las personas que atraviesan
estos momentos con vos en sexto grado
eran 20 año de primaria y yo sabía que
al finalizar lo iba a perder a muchos de
mis mejores amigos solamente por la
razón de que se cambiaran de colegio iba
a entrar a la secundaria y no iba a
encontrar la mitad de la clase sólo con
pensar eso me explotaba la cabeza
igualmente a mis ex compañeros los sigo
bien de todos pero no es lo mismo que
antes son y siguen siendo personas
extremadamente importantes para mí este
cambio me afectó a mí ya todos mis
compañeros de curso ya que éramos muy
unidos pero no sé si estos cambios yo
entendí que lo que estaba ocurriendo
pero nada más y nada menos el cierre de
una etapa tengo 12 años no vine un
cuarto de mi vida aún así que sobre mí
en vez de pensar que tengo que decirle
adiós a todo lo que viví compartí con
ellos tengo que decirles hola hay una
etapa que voy a comenzar
en los caminos y la gente quería conocer
los desafíos y obstáculos que me
conducen a la meta la vida se trata de
descubrir
la secundaria mi vuelta por completo
cambio todo lo que estaba a mi alrededor
me cambio de lo que era mi punto de
vista hasta lo que estaba acostumbrada a
ser además sólo cuando peces hace más
independiente la secundaria produce
inseguridad en seguridad economismo
después sobre ningún este volver en mis
manos inseguridad con el colegio con su
familia y con sus compañeros
un miedo que se siente al entrar a la
secundaria son los más grandes bueno al
principio piensa como los más grandes
mejorados normal solo por ser más
chiquito pero al final no es tan así
siempre hay alguno que se trata de medio
mal o no te callas también pero también
hay un montón que son súper bonao no
sólo es cuestión de tiempo para darse
cuenta
la secundaria me hizo pensar diferente
me olvidó diferentes cambios de
sentimientos todo el tiempo todo lo que
se me afecta y cambiarlo de mí si sé que
al entrar esta nueva etapa uno debe y
aprende a valorar
yo opino que por un lado hay que empezar
a madurar para aprobar materias pruebas
o tareas pero también por el otro lado
cada persona tiene su propio significado
de mejorar tales para uno madurar es
sacar una galletita del paquete sin
elegirla no valen sólo en el chocolate
uno no puede ser dos etapas por eso
tiene que adaptarse a cada una de ellas
una etapa es como el trayecto desde el
principio un puente hasta el final pero
muy difícil nos dará ninguna ruptura en
aquel trayecto
este proceso de atravesar las etapas
para adaptarse a perder de las cosas
nuevas y los cambios aunque en el medio
hay adentro que esos obstáculos
lo que venía y lo que me subió a través
de estos años es
es ser más independiente más responsable
aprender el valor de la amistad y en la
familia que los dolores y miedos se
superan que personas de otras personas
pasaron por situaciones similares a las
que yo pasé también aprendí que con el
tiempo la gente cambia su manera de
actuar y de pensar aparte durante la
secundaria ya que se producen muchos
cambios en lo mismo en los demás se
puede descubrir mis pasiones las cuales
son tocar instrumentos y hacer deportes
hay pocas maneras de atravesar las
etapas pero yo creo que la más efectiva
es siendo flexible y no acostumbrarnos a
lo cotidiano
se flexible mentalmente conlleva
mantener una actitud abierta una vez me
dijeron una frase que me hizo
reflexionar en vez de permanecer
inflexible y testaruda se adaptan de las
ráfagas del viento y no sucumba
lo que esta frase quiere decir es que en
vez de impedir y evitar que los cambios
lleguen a nuestra vida hay que
adaptarlos a ellos y abrir las puertas a
lo nuevo
no podemos evitar que los cambios de dos
etapas o tormentas que vienen
destrozarnos genera nuestra vida lo que
sí podemos hacer es mantener una actitud
flexible entendiendo de los problemas
como situaciones pasajeras aunque tienen
destruirnos no lo podrán hacer
[Aplausos]